[Musique]
cette chanson je survivrai de Michel
Richard accompagné Linda Grondin durant
Noël pour la première fois de sa vie
elle a passé les fêtes sans domicile
fixe et loin de sa famille j'espère que
le dernier là malgré tout trouvé une
famille temporaire tout au long du mois
de décembre le pavillon Patricia
McKenzie de la mission oldery organisé
des activités festives comme le
spectacle d'un imitateur d'helvis
les services pour femmes sans abri ont
hébergé plus de cinquantaine de femmes
dans les dernières semaines
Elisabeth travaille depuis une quinzaine
d'années auprès des femmes en situation
d'itinérance pour l'intervenante le
temps des fêtes il se célèbre avec elle
j'ai toujours travaillé les journées de
Noël les journées du jour de l'an parce
que pour moi c'est important d'être
présente puis il y a quelque chose de
effectivement magique qui qui
s'explique pas vraiment là qu'il faut
vivre pour comprendre les employ
bénéficier d'une aide précieuse
au coin du boulevard Saint-Laurent et de
la Clark plus de 125 bénévoles ont
contribué aux célébrations de Noël on a
eu des groupes de famille plus de 75
personnes sont nus servir les repas puis
en plus de ça on a eu environ une autre
cinquantaine de bénévoles qui sont venus
faire divers stages je connaissent
autant nos pavions pour femmes que nos
pavions pour hommes ici aussi les
services d'hébergement affichent complet
et les gens se tournent vers les
services d'urgence on parle de prix de
1000 personnes qui ont visité nos
refuges d'urgence ce nombre devrait
continuer d'augmenter avec l'arrivée des
temps froids en attendant Linda Grondin
travaille activement pour se retrouver
un logement et laisser sa place
elle aura toujours une chanson pour
l'inciter à continuer d'avancer
en France c'est naturellement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à Montréal